♪ ♪
>> Greg: ALL RIGHT, ACCORDING
TO A NEW CNN ARTICLE, TOO MUCH
BAD NEWS CAN MAKE YOU SICK.
WELL, THEY ARE THE EXPERTS.
THEY POINT TO SOCIAL MEDIA, NEW
TECHNOLOGY, 24-HOUR NEWS WHICH
ALLOWS YOU TO EXPERIENCE STUFF
YOU NEVER WOULD HAVE DECADES
AGO.
WHO COULD BE RESPONSIBLE FOR
THIS?
A MURDER IN ONE STATE, A TRAIN
CRASH, WILDFIRE, FLOOD, THEY ALL
COMMAND YOU AT ONCE.
IT OVERWHELMS YOU.
THAT COMES DISASTER FATIGUE.
HOW DOES THIS MAKE YOU SICK?
THE ARTICLE NEVER SHOWS ANY
STATISTICS ABOUT THAT.
IT'S ALL HYPOTHETICAL.
NO EVIDENCE.
MAYBE THERE COULD BE THE
PROBLEM, CNN.
HERE IS MY THEORY.
SOME BAD NEWS AT ALL THAT MAKES
YOU SICK.
IT'S THE "YOU ARE BAD NEWS."
WHEN EVERY STORY PAINTS U.S. THE
VILLAIN WHICH HAPPENS DAILY.
HERE IS BAD NEWS.
POLAR BEARS ARE DISAPPEARING.
HERE IS YOU ARE BAD NEWS.
IT'S BECAUSE YOU MISTREAT THE
PLANET.
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION IS UP.
HERE IS YOU ARE BAD IF IT BUGS
YOU, YOU MUST BE A BIGOT.
BAD NEWS: POLICE SHOULD A
MINORITY.
YOU ARE BAD NEWS: BECAUSE
AMERICA, YOU ARE RACIST.
HOW HEALTHY IS IT TO BE TOLD
HOURLY THAT YOU ARE HEARTLESS,
RACIST, AND KILLING THE EARTH?
THAT'S MOST NEWS EXCEPT HERE
BECAUSE WE KNOW YOU ARE A GOOD
PERSON.
HE WILL GET IN OTHER PLACES.
TO THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY, CNN IS
THEIR MEGAPHONE.
THEY HAVE THE SAME MESSAGE: YOU
ARE BAD.
EVERYTHING IS BORN THROUGH THE
SAME FILTER, THE CAMPUS.
IT CREATES ONE CONCLUSION.
YOU ARE THE OPPRESSOR.
YOU ARE GUILTY.
IF THAT DOESN'T MAKE YOU SICK,
RICHARD.
YOU KNOW WHAT I LOVE, DANA?
CNN HAD ANOTHER ARTICLE RIGHT
AFTER THAT AND IT WAS ABOUT HOW
AMAZING AMERICA IS REMEMBER YOU
HAVE A GREAT ECONOMY,
NORTH KOREA, LOW UNEMPLOYMENT.
WHY ARE PEOPLE SO SAD?
THAT WAS AN ACTUAL ARTICLE THAT
RAN AFTER THIS ONE.
CNN IS, THEY HAVE NO
SELF-AWARENESS.
>> Dana: WONDER ABOUT -- THE
POLL HE BEAR THAT OUT.
IF YOU ASK PEOPLE, DO YOU THINK
AMERICA IS MOVING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION?
ARE YOU OPTIMISTIC?
THOSE NUMBERS ARE HEADED IN A
POSITIVE DIRECTION.
IT MIGHT BE THAT THE PEOPLE
RUNNING THE HEADLINES, THE
PEOPLE OF THEIR PEER GROUP AND
THE PEOPLE THEY ARE FRIENDS
WITH, THEY ARE MISERABLE.
>> Greg: CONFIRMATION BIAS,
KIMBERLY BRADY WON'T FIND THAT
IT FOX NEWS BECAUSE WE
APPRECIATE THE VIEWER.
WE DON'T BELIEVE AMERICA IS
INHERENTLY EVIL LIKE THIS OTHER
JERK FACES AT THE OTHER CABLE
NETWORKS.
>> Kimberly: SCREW THEM.
WE ARE TOO BUSY BEING HAPPY AND
WINNING, RIGHT?
SUCH A GOOD POINT.
PEOPLE SAY THEY DON'T WANT TO
WATCH THE NEWS BECAUSE IT'S
UPSETTING.
YOU GET PERSONALLY BLAMED LIKE
IT RELATES TO LIKE AMERICA'S BAD
PLACE, AMERICANS ARE RACIST,
THAT AMERICANS ARE ONLY
CONCERNED ABOUT THEMSELVES.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE REAL FACTS
ABOUT WHAT'S GOING ON, WE ARE
ONE OF THE MOST GENEROUS
COUNTRIES IF NOT THE MOST
GENEROUS COUNTRY IN TERMS OF
HELPING OUT OTHER COUNTRIES.
WE HAVE GREAT RECORD ON
EMPLOYMENT NUMBERS NOW.
PEOPLE ARE BACK AT WORK.
THEY ARE ABLE TO PROVIDE FOR
THEIR FAMILY.
YOU SEE THE NUMBERS, WITH WOMEN
AND MINORITIES, AFRICAN-AMERICAN
COMMUNITY.
WE ARE TRYING TO DO EVEN MORE TO
IMPROVE PEOPLE'S LIVES.
THESE ARE THE POSITIVE GOOD NEWS
STORIES.
LIKE DANA'S BOOK.
PEOPLE WANT TO HEAR IT AND HEAR
ABOUT THE WINDS ARE NOT
CONSTANTLY BE MADE TO FEEL BAD
ABOUT THEMSELVES BECAUSE SOMEHOW
YOU'VE DONE SOMETHING TO BE A
BLIGHT ON THE REST OF THE WORLD
AND YOU ARE DESTROYING THE
ENVIRONMENT WHILE YOU'RE AT IT.
>> Greg: THEY TOUCHED ON
SOMETHING WE TALK ABOUT HERE,
THAT TECHNOLOGY AND CABLE TAKES
EVERY STORY MAKES IT NATIONAL.
WE THINK THAT ALL THE STUFF IS
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW.
>> Juan: I THOUGHT YOUR POINT
WAS WELL TAKEN.
HAD NO STATISTICAL BASIS.
BUT I MUST SAY I THINK THE POINT
YOU ARE NOW MAKING ABOUT EVERY
EARTHQUAKE, EVERY MURDER IS A
NATIONAL STORY, THAT'S ALSO TRUE
AND IT AFFECTS YOU.
A LOT OF PEOPLE DO, WHAT
KIMBERLY WAS DESCRIBING, SAYING
I DON'T WATCH NEWS AS MUCH AS I
USED TO BECAUSE THEY THINK,
ESPECIALLY IN OUR AUDIENCE, THAT
IS ALL NASTY TRUMP STUFF AND
THEY DON'T WANT TO HEAR IT BUT
SECONDLY, A LOT OF IT IS
DEPRESSING.
EVERY STATION DOES BREAKING
NEWS, BREAKING NEWS.
WHAT IS THIS?
IT CATCHES YOUR EYEBALL.
IT'S ALMOST LIKE AN INVOLUNTARY
RESPONSE.
YOUR HEAD SWINGS TO THE TV.
I FIND IT ODD COMING FROM MR. "I
HATE THESE PEOPLE" THAT YOU ARE
SAYING WE ARE THE LOVE BOAT
RIGHT HERE AT FOX NEWS.
>> Greg: THAT'S TRUE.
I AM A HYPOCRITE.
YOU GOT ME THERE.
YOU DO A NEWS PROGRAM.
I BELIEVE IT'S IN THE MORNINGS.
IS IT A LOCAL PROGRAM?
>> Brian: IT'S GOING TO BE
NATIONAL.
>> Greg: IT'S A DELIGHTFUL
SHOW.
YOU HAVE COOKING SEGMENTS.
>> Brian: WE USED TO HAVE PET
OF THE DAY.
RATINGS GOT TOO HIGH.
65% SAY THEY FOLLOW THE NEWS
MOST OF THE TIME.
68% SAID THEY ARE WORN OUT BY
THE NEWS.
HERE'S WHAT I SAY.
WHEN PRESIDENT OBAMA,
PRESIDENT BUSH WAS PRESIDENT,
THE ONE THING WITH FOX AND WE
DON'T PROGRAM THE SAME STORY.
LOOK HOW DIFFERENT THE SHOW'S.
LOOK HOW DIFFERENT OUR SHOW IS.
THERE IS NOT "TRUMP IS GREAT,"
"OBAMA IS BAD."
"BUSH IS FANTASTIC."
WE SWITCH GEARS.
45 MINUTES ABOUT BAD TRUMPETERS
IN 15 MINUTES ON HOW THEY WISH
OPRAH WAS PRESIDENT.
SHOWS A PROGRAM, IF YOU WATCH
HERE, PEOPLE ARE HAPPIER.
I WOULD LIKE CNN DO A STUDY ON
WHY FOX VIEWERS ARE HAPPIER.
WE HAVE A DIVERSITY OF VIEWS AND
ALLOWS YOU TO GET INFORMATION
AND FORM YOUR OWN OPINION.
>> Greg: WHEN YOU FEEL BAD
WATCHING THE NEWS.